All right, I'm just going to walk you through ChatGPT deep research.
So it's a button here that you press, and you can deal with the different models.
In particular, if you have the $200 a month pro account, then it works really well, because
the pro model is much better at thinking through things, and then it can come up with
better things to research.
Just going to ask a question here.
I use this primarily for researching scientific papers or topics that I need to understand deeply.
So I'm going to say, why didn't Mometix become a science versus a cultural evolution?
Which seems to have become the dominant path for studying evolution of ideas.
And when you submit, quite often it will ask you specific questions, because it wants to
get it right.
And it is quite a lengthy process, so it is important that you answer it.
Normally, I would actually spend a lot more time on the prompt, depending on a few different
directions.
But specifically, why, from an incentive's point of view, did cultural evolution adopted
over Mometix by scientists?
Okay, and that's doing the research.
It typically can take anywhere from a few minutes to 10, 20 minutes in some cases.
If you click on it, you can usually see what things it's read on the right hand side here.
You'll be able to see what sources it looks at, too.
Okay, you can see here that it's gone through one of the sources already, this MIT source,
and it's telling you what it's looking at.
It's going to keep doing that for a while, keep thinking, and then keep going back different
sources.
It's actually writing the Google search queries in order to find these sources as well, which
is what makes it so powerful.
And then we'll decide when it has enough information to give you your answer.
So it will think a lot longer for things a bit more difficult, and it will come back
much more directly if it gets an answer quicker.
Okay, it looks like we have everything back, and it did an astounding amount of work.
It looked at 28 different sources from Stanford to like Wikipedia and neuroanthropology.net.
Tons of really interesting sources that you could always go and check for yourself, but
it also gives you all the thinking that went into this, and you can understand this thought
process as it comes on.
All right, so we have like now a pretty comprehensive report.
One of the main things is that memetics was less testable.
There's also more interdisciplinary integration in Cultural Revolution.
And also there were better institutional funding incentives because it was easier to get at
some of the big questions of Cultural Revolution with these existing funding
mechanisms.
Yeah, pretty interesting.
You could go read all these references if you want.
You could also ask it more information.
Now it has these sources that it's found.
It could also go and add more stuff to it as well.
You could also ask to summarize if you needed to.
Typically, I'll take this and I'll copy it, and I'll paste it into Claude.
And then I will ask Claude to summarize it in a tweet or something like that.
Claude is a little bit more creative, and these reports end up being relatively dry.
But they are amazingly well researched, and that's the main reason to use
something like deep research.